hello and welcome to this video playing
it was CBO mmm babylon those complicated
names running okay is playing him d4 g3
setup it's a bit like a catalan but I
got the bishop on a5 so that it doesn't
look very threatening however of course
White's position is very solid I hope
that I can make this video without much
interruption there so yeah construction
work is a little bit strong but they are
installing a new worm agate outside of
my my room and it's a bit noisy now that
feels ok now not ofor before that it
felt a bit like a digital like I had
this on the board before and it wasn't
what it crate before was more worried
about eform yeah I think I should be
very ok the c3 Knight looks like
substantial liability especially the
rook being only one that is a factor ok
so what does y do now and you cannot
move the knight and where would you for
what you do now 92 sorry Queen d2 that
looks very unnatural even I have Queen
takes a two against that I know they
know we got construction let's see how
that goes
anyway I really don't see what White's
move is now
yeah something crazy it's kind of what I
would have thought okay if I take one
this Knight is 7 lightly so just take it
yeah I think he really had a huge huge
problem already okay so maybe justice
that covers covers d5 indirectly and the
bishop only three will be nice so ever
put this bishop here and now it should
be falling if I can get rid of this
Bishop that would be cool but okay let's
not be fancy Knight b6 covers d5 and he
really doesn't have any good move here
Queen d2 is a simple way to continue
okay so me a queen f4 nothing wrong
about it
white queen doesn't really have any
we're good to go to know yeah I think I
think yeah that that looked all fairly
normal but b3 is probably doesn't really
help all that much and I actually missed
something special before as it's
stronger but okay 97 thank you for maybe
yeah but okay here
why should just play you for I thought
take-take-take but I now recognize can
actually grab be 5 that makes the whole
whole lot of difference if something
like that I mean I'm definitely fine
there there's nothing wrong about my
position here rather better but after a
forehead you're in huge trouble
efore before still putting up more
resistance after look see one who
created estrus gone just a deadly pin
by the way I'm now working I said that
would have been an interesting move
Queen cannot take because of the pin but
he has tonight before him and this is an
indeed not clear if I take this here
there are there are some some
interesting possibilities it's
interesting the engine actually think
that is full compensation not you know
that's kind of believable right yes it's
just gone yeah Queen d2 I was expecting
this but and I'll see that d4 is
entirely killing I was now I saw this
one which also should win but was funky
it's terrible but devoid of course even
more convincing and the Queen again
cannot take you to this yeah and then
then he went into an act an ik mode but
it's already lost you cannot cannot save
this nothing much here is only I'm just
entering with the Queen or Queen gets
traded and I'm already Pisa
okay guys thanks for watching